do you ever feel like a problem occurs
and you don't know how to solve it and
you're the cast is looking at you and
you just I'm a little of I'm out of
my and does it ever get like amped up
like I have I have found over time that
I get if I'm if a problem appear you
know like the the wind blows over the
set and now what are we gonna do I know
that those things are going to happen
and I just get very Zen about it I'm
like all right let's figure out how
we're gonna solve that and because I
think I went through such a trial by
fire on my very first thing Wet Hot
American Summer where it poured rain
every single day almost every day when
you're filming that right daylight
exterior short low budget shoot it's
supposed to be a nice day all it all
takes place in one sunny day and pouring
pouring rain all day and so it was the
ultimate daily like what the are we
gonna do situation and I learned then
it's like to let go of what's out of
your control focus on what you what
Solutions might be in front of you and
just do it and and somehow on set with
that structure I thrive you know where
you don't have to think about what am I
going to do today you know what you've
got you've got to get up and do it and
so
the I I don't I don't think I would do
well to be like someone who's always in
production and so if I was working on a
camera crew or something where every day
of my life I've that I work that I have
to do that I think I would burn out but
I really love the thing I love the most
about my life and my work is that it
changes all the time sometimes you're
really mellow and you're working with
one person in a room by yourself or
sometimes you're with a small crew doing
something and or you're on set being the
general of an army of 100